ciao gentaglia sono shooter ace e questo
è breaking italy lo shock è in onda
lunedì al venerdì nel quale parliamo di
cosa succede non è più o meno ci ha
provato dai oggi parliamo di kinder
parliamo di un argomento un po
particolare perché alla fine come scrivo
nel titolo no è da sfigati usare team
del punto interrogativo perché la gente
lo usa ma non lo dice come mai questa
col come ma come mai c'è paura di dire
che usiamo tingerà fine è un social day
fatto apposta per incontrare le persone
quindi per chi non lo sapesse ma
dovreste aver vissuto sotto una pietra
praticamente c'è quest'app dove tu puoi
iscriverti con questo profilo mettere la
tua foto mettere se sei interessato a un
uomo donna entrambi insomma per
conoscere per lo più si fa per conoscere
una persona con la quale costruire
qualcosa oppure per andarci ad ely
scorso è proprio questo nel senso che
molti hanno paura di esporsi e quindi
usano tender ma non lo dicono che è
infatti c'è un'opzione di tender che ti
permette di non match artificiale vuol
dire quando due persone si mettono laica
vicenda e quindi entrano in contatto su
twitter si apre la chat elicoidali puoi
iscriverti poi tutti i scrivi su tender
devi mettere il tuo numero di telefono e
c'è questa opzione che toglie tutte le
persone della tua rubrica che usano
tender dai possibili match quindi i tuoi
amici non ti vedranno mai su tender
perché loro si sono iscritti coloro
numero et inter fa in modo che tu e
questa persona che conosci non vi
vediate mai e quindi non si crea
quell'imbarazzo letta mossa geniale tra
l'altro però
perché c'è cosa c'è di negativo
nell'usare tender
adesso vi dico le mie considerazioni
allora io non ho mai usato kinder vi
dico la verità perché quando è uscito
poi io nella mia posizione non ho mai
avuto bisogno nel senso che quando
volevo conoscere qualcuno per riuscirci
infatti tutte le persone con cui sono
stato me l'hanno scritto nei dm di
instagram ok oppure su facebook quindi
questo perché io sono timido come la
quindi non mi sento mai di andare tipo a
una festa a parlare con qualcuno
quindi sempre tramite messaggi non ho
mai fatto quasi mai fatto io la prima
mossa rarissimo
quindi non ho mai utilizzato t nel male
avrei utilizzato anzi in realtà l'ho
fatto ultimamente per vedere come
funzionava e perché no ho detto magari
funziona veramente quindi possono
veramente baciare con una persona che
vuole costruire qualcosa l'ho tenuto tre
giorni incrocia quello disinstallato
perché non sono uno che utilizza molto
il telefono in generale quindi non mi
andava riaprirla per stare però voluto
provare a vedere comesto timber che
tutti hanno utilizzato tutti hanno
utilizza quasi tutti non tutti però
tutti
hanno utilizzato o hanno pensato di
utilizzare e non c'è niente di male non
c'è niente ma smettiamola di dare qui
pregiata usati nessuno ride ride nessuno
credo che il problema sia l'italia
non sto scherzando aver paura di dire
che si usa tendere un problema che c'è
in italia perché all'estero questo non
c'è ve lo assicuro non c'è vi faccio un
esempio chiaro il soldato in canada ok
ho conosciuto delle persone
questo mio viaggio incredibile in camera
tutte queste persone certo punto uscito
fuori l'argomento di tender tutte queste
persone avevano utilizzato tender ma ne
parlavano con una tranquillità
incredibile anzi si no
ma teatro all'estero e ho usato molto
molto di più che che in italia tra
l'altro
ea quasi sostituito il modo tradizionale
di conoscere una persona è una roba
incredibile
a fuori all'estero è utilizzato
tantissimo io credo questo non lo so
perché non ho visto dati statistici ma
credo potrei sbagliarmi che la maggior
parte delle persone si conosca grazie a
teen days oggi invece che andando in
giro cioè per farvi capire credo è non
lo so però a giudicare da quante persone
che ho conosciuto all'estero che l'hanno
usato e che hanno trovato la propria
meta contender mi fa capire quanto in
realtà è utilizzato in italia se ne
sente parlare poco o meglio
quando se ne sente palais poco perché
poca gente ammette di usarlo ma non c è
un motivo è perché abbiamo sempre in
italy abbiamo sempre sti pregiudizi
strani però non hai capito perché in
italia la gente alla gente frega
moltissimo di più che negli altri paesi
dell'opinione che la gente ha di sé
ok questa cosa in italia credo che credo
sempre sono mie opinioni e ragazzi ma
credo che ci sia di più che all'estero
cioè in italia la gente ha paura di
essere giudicata molto più che
all'estero ok perché se tu vuoi fare una
cosa la fa e cioè nel senso
ovviamente nei limiti però se tu fai
vuoi fare kinder po fi vuoi conoscere lo
fai non c'è nessun problema nessuno tipo
da ridere se parte che se qualcuno ti
deride perché ti vede si tingerà anche
lui sta usando tenda vabbè ma chi se ne
frega ce n'è chi se ne frega nessuno
nessuno deve vietarsi di fare un qualche
cosa per paura di essere giudicato però
mi dispiace che in italia ancora ci sia
questa mentalità molto forse molto retrò
non so dove dove il parere degli altri e
più importante di quello che noi
pensiamo di noi stessi e sbagliatissimo
sbagliatissimo perché alla fine ci si
preclude le possibilità per niente per
chi perché mi fa felice il tuo amico che
non sa che sa tanto di ma che cazzo
cazzo te ne frega poi per carità sempre
fare attenzione quando ci sono queste
cose perché non sai mai chi c'è
dall'altra parte sempre le solite cose
come in tutti i social ovviamente vi
racconto in chiusura la mia esperienza e
la mia esperienza continua e durata poco
praticamente questo è successo io mi
sono iscritta timbre e all'inizio prima
di capire tutto questo discorso perché
l'ho capito poi sulla mia pelle quando
l'ho tolto detto ma perché mi sono
vergognato
non c'era bisogno però all'inizio come
tutti quanti aveva un attimo di va bene
dai facciamolo
ok e l'ho fatto e quindi per paura
sbagliando perché mi sono poi reso conto
del mio errore ho avuto paura di essere
giudicato per qualche stranissimo motivo
poi io che sono un personaggio pubblico
sai corri su tender ti esce fa vj
avrei usato che poi chissenefrega l'ho
capito dopo però vabbè per ovviare a
questo problema ho fatto i cui 2000 ho
preso le mie foto del profilo instagram
ok quindi foto già pubbliche
ho creato un account che potrebbe essere
davvero creato chiunque con le mie foto
pubbliche ok quindi non l'ho verificato
e ho messo come target come target di
ragazze danneggiare come target ho messo
dai 26 che la mia età fino ai 30 ok io
ho tolto tutta non è che non mi seguono
persone dai 26 30 però è una minima
parte
ok la media adesso secondo me sui venti
più o meno e questa è stata la mia
strategia per andare un po di keys nichi
non avrei non ha senso anche perché ve
lo dico solo per farvi capire mi hanno
detto in canada poi non so quanto sia
vero che leonardo di caprio satinder di
caprio cielo diga dai
o magari sono bello come sapete ho fatto
un seminario mesi fa dove mi hanno
spiegato che ogni persona deve vivere la
propria il proprio essere
come si sente di viverlo senza aver
paura di essere giudicati perché tanto
alla fine cercare di essere quello che
non siamo per far piacere agli altri non
attira più persone vicino a noi
rispetto a quelle cattive destra essendo
voi stessi attira lo stesso numero di
persone ma quelle sbagliate perché non
siete voi stessi l'importante è essere
se stessi e arrivano le persone dello
stesso numero di persone che
arriverebbero se non foste voi stessi e
ma tentando di piacere solo che arrivano
le persone giuste perché voi siete voi
stessi quindi arrivano le persone giuste
siate voi stessi sempre ok siamo in
questa perla
kafkiana
che poi questo kafkiano chi è
iscrivetevi al canale servizio è
piaciuto l'argomento mi piace fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate come sempre in
tutti questi video creiamo un po di
dibattito perché vuole sapere le vostre
opinioni e un bacino e noi ci vediamo
come sempre ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]